Brazil.
[Silence]
Another thing
that the prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam encouraged with respect to
fasting
is that a person fast 3 days from every
month.
That a person fast 3 days from every
[Arabic recitation]
what that means to say I am the daddy
what had he do for say I am
what you say to have one to go I am
I shall rather
what comes out of that
laugh at her
go on and what I am you say to have one
to go I am
you have no say I am I say I am I am
what do you say I am
I say I am that he is saying
lucky you say to have one to go I am
and you go on
and you go I say I am
I am
I say I am I am
what do you say I am I am what comes out
of that
you want to say I shall rather my yak
mellow and better
So
one of the
one of the options fast which the
prophet
Ali was selling encouraged and he didn't
just encourage any person with this
fast.
Actually, he encouraged one of his
greatest
followers
one of his greatest
students
one of the great scholars of the
companions Abdullah bin Omar bin Al-As.
Abdullah bin Omar bin Al-As
single-handedly
for a time carried
the knowledge front of a sham entirely.
Abdullah bin Omar bin Al-As is one of
the greatest scholars to ever have gone
to
to a sham.
And so
Abdullah bin Omar bin Al-As when he met
the prophet
Ali was selling of course, his father
had accepted Islam, Amr ibn al-As,
and his son, Abdullah, accepted Islam,
and he was full of youth and full of
vigor, and he was very very
enthusiastic,
very strict with himself.
And
so one day his father,
Amr ibn al-As,
went to his house,
his son's house.
And his son had just gotten married.
You know, usually when a person just get
gets married, it's what we call the
honeymoon,
you know, time.
And so he found that his wife kanat
mutabathilatun.
She wasn't particularly
dressed a young woman would be in
her own home for her husband.
She was
dressed in a way that she has no one to
impress.
And so she asked, being that she's a
newlywed,
and she said,
"Your son
is one of the greatest men,
but he has no use for women."
Meaning,
all he's constantly doing is praying,
reading the Quran,
and fasting,
and he barely looks at me.
And so Amr ibn al-As informed the
[Arabic recitation]
this.
commanded him to moderate, to moderate
his
fasting, to moderate his recitation, to
moderate his salah. At the time, he was
fasting every single day.
At the time, he was reciting the
entirety of the Quran every single day.
And at the time, he was praying from
the moments of Isha all the way until
the break of Fajr every single day.
This was his routine.
So, if someone comes and tries to apply
this now
and says,
"Hey, remember what happened to Abdullah
ibn Amr ibn al-As?
You're not supposed to be extreme unless
this is what's happening."
That doesn't really apply. Apples and
oranges.
This is what Abdullah was doing.
Was this because
of his arrogance or was this because
he was showing off? No, he was doing
this genuinely. He genuinely
was attempting
to
receive the good graces of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And so, the Prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam commanded him to
moderate these
these things. So, one of the things that
he told him was summin kulli shahrin
thalathata ayyam.
He said, "Of every month, fast 3 days."
Remember, we're going from
every single day to
3 days a month.
He knew that Abdullah was not going to
stay at that if he could if he could
help it. He was going to ask for more.
But,
it's kind of bargaining. You know
when you go to bargain with someone that
is Let's say you got something to sell,
I want to buy it.
It's a 100 bucks.
I'm willing to pay 80.
I'll start at 50.
Which I know you're not going to accept,
but I got to start you somewhere, right?
So that we end up where
we end up in the middle, in the
middle ground.
And so, he began with the lowest in all
of these.
He told him to
recite the Quran
once a month.
He's going from every single day to
Of course, he's going to ask for more.
He is going from every single day
fasting to
three times, 10%.
Of course, he's going to ask for more.
But the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam understands something about
human nature. And that is when someone
is in extreme,
you have to be extreme in pulling them
back to the middle.
So that they end up where?
In the middle.
You can see this pattern all throughout.
And so,
he tells him to fast from every month 3
days.
Then he says,
for
every
hasana, every merit is counted at least
how much?
10 times.
And 3 days every month
with that calculation will be equivalent
to fasting the entirety of the year.
The author then tells us,
and it is preferred
that the days, the 3 days he chooses
are
the 13th, 14th, and 15th. Notice now the
author,
he begins with the sunnah is 3 days, any
3 days.
Because fasting is salah.
There are days when you are not allowed
to fast.
Anything else you are allowed to, right?
I mean, look at the way that the
exception is made.
When it comes to salah, optional prayer,
right? We are not told necessarily when
to pray optional prayer. We are told
when we are not to pray optional prayer.
Right after Fajr till the sun rises,
right after Asr until the sun sets,
just before Dhuhr until the sun crosses
its zenith. These are the times when we
are not to pray.
And we understand from this that
anything outside of the three points is
what? A time to pray.
Whenever you have extra time, whenever
you can, whenever you want to, you pray.
You pray extra.
Right? The same thing with fasting. We
are not necessarily told when to fast,
we're told the best times to fast, but
we're not necessarily told when to fast.
We are told when we are not permitted to
fast.
What are those days? Well, we have a
whole chapter about that. The days of
Eid and Friday on its own and Saturday
on its own as we'll hear.
Which is to be understood that outside
of those prohibited times, any time you
can fast is good. And
it's important that it's that
because people's schedules change.
Sometimes people
cannot fast when they're working,
sometimes people can't fast when they're
So,
fasting is to their leisure. They can
fast whenever they choose to fast. And
so, the Prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam encouraged that a person
capitalize on the opportunity to fast
whenever it presents itself.
So,
he told Abdullah ibn Amr here, fast 3
days a month.
If a person decided to fast the 1st,
2nd, and 3rd of every month, is that
permissible?
Permissible. Would he have fulfilled
this narration? No.
Right? He would have fulfilled. But what
is the best?
The best is 13, 14, 15. Same thing with
salah.
The best time to make salah at night is
which part of the night?
Last third. It's the last third of the
night. But if a person were to make
his salah, his qiyam, right after he's
finished with Isha every night, would it
be correct? Yes, it would be correct.
Would it be qiyam? Yes, it would be
qiyam, technically.
But the best night time is the last
third. Same thing with the fasting. The
best time to fast is 13, 14, 15. Why?
Because it's right smack dab in the
middle of the month, and it is the time
when the
moon is full. When the when the moon is
full.
[Silence]
He says,
"And the evidence for
the best 3 days for a person to choose
are 13, 14, and 15 is the narration of
Abu Dharr, radiyallahu anhu.
Abu Dharr narrates
that the Messenger of Allah sallallahu
alayhi wasallam said,
"Oh Abu Dharr,
if you fast 3 days from every month,
then make them the 13th, 14th, and
15th." This narration has been collected
by Tirmidhi
and Abu Dawud al-Sijistani in his Sunan.